[Music]
well I always say on the FISA
application especially that you know
you've heard Comey call it a mosaic and
it's just playing yeah people need to
see what's there because I think they
would cringe if they knew what the
government was willing to do to its
citizens house Intel committee ranking
member Devin Ennis on our show last
night discussing FISA warrant abuse
committed by yes upper echelon high
ranking officials in the FBI why to spy
on the Trump campaign Oh Jim Comey says
we didn't spy
he signed the first FISA warrant a US
citizen who was caught up in this
massive scandal our next guest on this
Hannity deep state special quarter-page
I know you're listening I know this
impacted you you lived through it but
you in a sense we're being used as a
conduit into all things Trump campaign
but you were spied on how many times
well there were those four applications
Sean and who knows there's the the
details as they keep coming out it just
keeps getting worse and worse so we
shall say do look it's one American
citizen Carter should not these are
civil liberties constitutional liberties
and it bothers me that you know short of
Alan Dershowitz and our friend Doug
Schon who's here not many on the left
seem to care it's like the ends
justifies the means what do you want the
American people to know now that you
know you were a victim of this well I've
had my feelings about it throughout the
whole time is that really this was as
you are alluding to it was not an attack
on me it was an attack on
candidate Trump and the entire Trump
movement and then it continued as
president-elect Trump and then into his
new administration so really that's
where the greatest damage was and
sometimes to step on how poor meet with
you you know I really lost track Sean
multiple times and you know it was a spy
do you know who he was there to spy on
you know and it was in a point in my
life when I was under so much pressure
with these false stories starting in
September 2016
really I was being shunned by pretty
much everyone except a few family
members and did you ever friends and one
person tell community that you would
tell us well now it's been exposed that
I was a informant for both the CIA and
FBI and actually it's funny because
these were these reports about you know
people like Brennan and clapper saying
well we don't want to expose informants
well if you read the Muller report they
talk about Alexander bulatov and that's
someone I was talking russian based in
new york i was giving information to the
FBI about so so there was no and they
interviewed you they knew who you were
and they knew you did nothing wrong they
knew your american citizen that was
debriefed often absolutely absolutely
all right Carter thank you for being
ones